damit der hollywood wasser hat vorjahr
nur zwölf minuten
murat ernsthaft weil die leute denken
immer das macht dass ich der böse bin da
war ich der dap schilder bist du hier
versteht was ich meine ja ich bin ein
ganz normaler friedlicher bürger auch
immer meine bin okay alles da los so ok
koch kommission zutaten und dann ganz
ganz einfach wir haben hier vier eier
größe s und zwar größer ist warum weil
das einfach von dem was ist es ein
kleines huhn
auch wenn man ein kleines who und das
kleine hunger kleiner eingelegt und die
sind vom bauern bist du was bist du für
klose
ich bin größer also drei ich habe vier
kleine eier größe s und wenn jetzt nicht
hat mir einfach drei eier größe m
man kann auch immer einmal mehr nehmen
es schadet nicht den rest will ich nicht
so bestätigen weil der kölner im schaden
man sieht ihr das kann wirklich nachher
wissen auch okay was soll da haben wir
milch und zwar weil ich habe hier weil
ich nicht unterschätzen
ich guck mal ganz kurz doch jetzt sieht
man ja der graue star 250 mill ich habe
mir dann haben wir hier ja eine prise
salz und ein esslöffel zucker ok und
haben wir hier mal mit dem hammer mail
diese e mail haben wir 250 52 jahren
hatte auch gesehen ja dann haben wir ein
teelöffel war extra kann man ruhig ein
bisschen mehr behandelt da passiert die
erwachsen geworden und da mehr und bei
der em
dann haben wir hier butter und zwar
geschmolzene butter
nein noch nicht wirklich böse schmerzen
55 gramm produkt und die haben auch 100
gramm kilogramm butter das ist ja und da
haben wir hier wasser muskel butter
haben wir zum mineralwasser das ist ganz
ganz wichtig und so hat dieses
mineralwasser haben wir noch mal
doch nichts wirklich 150 250 milliliter
mineralwasser warum ist mineralwasser im
crap teig eigentlich so richtig kann das
mal an klubs wird ja genau damit er
schön fluffig hast du schon okay was
haben wir noch alle wissen alle unsere
zutaten die wir jetzt mit ihm zusammen
in der schüssel vermengen werden dazu
brauchen natürlich erstmal schön du hast
ja ein schütze und ich nehme dann
endlich meine erwachsene ein fan wollte
mich noch gedanken bei dir für das t
shirt für welches team schafft winter
das erzählen kannst
ich bin nicht perfekt aber verdammt nah
dran so hat das ist ehrlich ja das habe
ich war das nicht geschieht können wir
ihnen beim aus den filmen ich finde es
einfach nur grauenhaft
ja genau ich mir ja genau müssen den
jugendschutz denken deswegen kann man
bin ich nicht beim umziehen filme weil
sonst einige kinder vielleicht irgendwie
traumatisches erlebt
dann haben wir hier eine schlagschüsse
ja das ist ein schlag schüssel besonders
ist
ja sie ist der schlaf ist ein
produktplatzierung so was haben wir da
machen wir folgen ist als allererstes
nehmen wir das mehl und tun das in die
schüssel rein so jetzt haben wir ein
gemacht und dann wenn man das gemacht
haben dann machen wir die molkereien und
zwar kann man es mit meiner faust machen
mit einer harmlosen deine haare
nein habe ich nicht so auch immer ihr
seht ihr eine haarige faust reingemacht
machen wir das schnelle ja und genau die
position beispiel abkühlen kann genau
die butter schmelzen
damit sie abkühlen kann weiter gehts
dann nehmen wir diese eier und schlagen
sie in das in die faust in harmonie
wurde sozusagen die mutter maria
und dann dann nehmen wir hier die eier
und schlagen sie rein
und ganz ganz wichtig nach mitternacht
immer die eingeschlagen hat die hände
waschen weil die ganzen salmonellen
haben sollte dann befinden sich die
salmonellen auch immer auf der schale
jetzt haben sie rein gemacht und zwar in
die mulde und jetzt nehmen diesen küchen
roboter und tun das ding rühren bitte
hand röhre
ja und ich tue ihm derzeit meine hände
waschen
ok und immer mehr derzeit ist so richtig
erhöht lässige mehr richtig hören immer
ein schluck wasser und schlucken milch
mit rein geben so das zeigt eine schöne
sämige konsistenz bekommt und zwar wie
ungefähr man zahlen kann ich die wand
habe alpina wandfarbe weiß das produkt
was jetzt auch merkt die aktionen nicht
gemerkt aber ich habe sofort gemerkt und
zwar ist der teig so richtig gelb max
ist gerade eigentlich mal schauen so
richtig schön und es ist wahnsinnig gelb
der teig ist das merkst du wirklich wenn
du wenn du bio-eier nimmst das sind die
immer geld hast musst ja
eines ist außerdem unter oder gelb so
oder so ergeben auf die die prise salz
noch dazu in zucker ich bin meinen
extrakt und dann geben wir noch mal
milch hinzu
gehen wir mal was hinzu
[Musik]
und das problem ist die bruder darf
nicht zu heiß sein weil sonst gerinnt
euch das passt mir nicht bewusst muss es
einfach so unterschiedlichen crêpes und
ist ein pfannkuchen ist der unterschied
in der khl erst ganz grün genau wenn ich
jetzt mal stärke und entsorgen das ist
der unterschied
dort kann es jetzt immer die flüssige
butter
[Applaus]
danach wieder ins jahr wie sie ja jetzt
aber die butter machen und zu heißen
da passiert und ich glaub mir vertrauen
ich habe mein leben schon ich habe krebs
land jahrelang zwischen 72 und 78
in montreal habe ich gehabt im herbst 17
da war doch was
so sei man aber es ist nichts so willst
aber die butter mit eingerührt jetzt
aber das zu einer homogenen masse und
was wir jetzt machen ist einfach gut
abschneidet weil wir weil wir jetzt das
ding einfach ruhen lassen okay jetzt
auch nicht so jetzt haben wir das
berührt und jetzt schon mal einfach
diesen diesen deckel drauf wahnsinn
wahnsinn das ist noch offen
jahrhundert passiert nichts angeboten
ich glaub mir und da lassen wir das
ungefähr 30 minuten ruhen und ich bin ja
auch übernehmen oder auch holen ja und
dann warum lassen meistens genau das
heißt ja immer genau du weißt doch gar
nichts mehr mit als okay so wenn wir das
ding und unsere jetzt glaube ich das
schwierigste teil dieses ganzen rezept
ein bisschen schwierig weil jetzt zwei
möglichkeiten immer geht es im laden und
bin einfach mit fertigen packen vanille
sowie sehr grün jetzt machen würde
oder macht so wie ich jetzt und machten
manipulieren selber sauber gemacht hat -
also und dann um den mangel polizei
machen brauchen wir von einem gratis und
topf auf jeden fall machen wir 500
milliliter milch ein
dann nehmen wir zwei esslöffel wann
exakt
kann ein bisschen mehr sein weil es ja
vanille telefon noch zwei spiele wird
man den extrakt jetzt 2 und dann nehmen
wir vier mal gelb und zwar vier mal gelb
von 454 ist macht ihr ein
dann haben wir haben wir 100 gramm
zucker nun alles wieder
ich habe kloß im hals dann nehmen wir
genau die ein auto per 1
dann nehmen wir ungefähr 100 gramm
zucker und eine prise salz eine prise
salz 100 gramm zucker sollte zum
industriekonzern habe mir noch stärker
und zwar stärke ist ja auch ganz ganz
wichtig und zwar die stärke sorgt für
das sortiment meisters und zwar möbel
stärke brauchen ja konsistenz des
puddings 45 stärke und 40 gramm stärke
zumal auch hier ein
aber noch mal irgendwas war hier drin
egal
passt schon so da haben wir das rein
gemacht jedes rezept übrigens könnte
anschauen bei seliges blog.de
da schreibt sie meine frau noch mal auf
die macht das richtig nicht so billig
wie nie genau
und jetzt hat er wohl wieder herum
rühren wo wir jetzt wird es kurz langsam
aufkochen lassen dass kurz richtig schön
quellen zur quelle und gequält ist dann
lasst uns oder abkühlen rechte politik
schon fertig machen sie mich schneller
ist brutal oder eigentum einer minute
ist und vorher gemacht darf ich ganz
kurzen ja weißt du eigentlich mit
nachnamen
okay okay sagt muss kurz aufkochen und
zwar kurz hoch
herschel ist brender der an und
erscheint jetzt als aufgekocht es seht
ihr auch an den an der struktur so und
jetzt machen wir einfach so jetzt muss
runter hören wie lange noch ein bisschen
hier noch auf kochen bis man merkt dass
es liegt wird ok ich muss aber schon
ja das sieht das schon kurz zerstört
wird der hund hat man eine struktur zu
stellen okay das ist jetzt langsam
merkel ein konsistentes riecht auch
schon nach anfänglich das riecht nach
vanille pudding und bei dir riemann
juni an okay dann haben wir es fertig
und jetzt thomas er hier in die schüssel
rein
das sind keine poppel dass ich meine das
ist vanilleschoten mark extra ist da
reifen mit zeichentrick und zwar für
merck ist so ein richtig vanilli
vanillecreme konsistenz also ganz ganz
wichtig aufpassen
ich bin ja also diese folie und diese
frischhaltefolie danke hinter und dann
kann die freischaltung von vanille
pudding reindrücken so seht ihr das
damit es keine haut gibt genau das
könnte übrigens auch machen wenn jetzt
seine lieder haben könnte das auch
machen und dann bekommt er keine elite
haus die haupt- und bürger die an
[Musik]
so sieht es aus mit der vanille pudding
die geister wahnsinnig haben heute die
vier ersten fünf minuten im morast zu
bekommen dann haben wir das jetzt machen
wir einfach
jetzt lassen wir uns einfach noch ganz
wichtig espresso
jetzt haben wir hier diesen diesen crap
teig und zwar ganz wichtig wenn ihr
merkt dass hier klümpchen in ihrem
inneren kräfte da drin haben so wenn es
gemerkt habt dann habt ihr vielleicht
noch die butter zu warm reingemacht hat
köpfchen gemacht dann könnte es mit dem
sieg aus sieben also nicht dass wir das
jetzt gemacht haben bei unserer zeit hat
sofort gepasst genau und wie gesagt da
müssen echt gucken das ist der
kräftigste schön flüssig ist und dass
man auch folgendes jetzt gehen wir hin
tun dass ich komme einfach mit dem mut
back gespräch genau so wie ein löffel ja
und eine frau zu fragen ist es nicht
sammer hatte gar nix leider sie ist gar
nicht so gute alte gesagt mir fehlt ein
löffel ort bereit also ehrlich
sie wird ihren pfannkuchenteig von
cryptic machen können jetzt macht wie
ihre kirmes kennst dich auch so eine
lange jahre lang bei der bahn gearbeitet
jetzt haben wir gemerkt und zwar habe
das falsche feld an hat nicht gemerkt
dass ich gemerkt ich musste mich immer
testen
ja ich komme mir vor wie dem sein
bewährungshelfer jetzt richtig schön
heiß werden lassen und zwar gehen wir
hier auf boost nein wir nichts man hier
nicht auch privat ein paar
das beginne sagt nein noch den
unterschiedlichen theologischen ganz
ganz einfach so machen schon mal alles
schön langsam gemütlich und bist du das
du bist du mein haus gebaut hat muss
schon wieder renovieren will so lange
brauchen stichwort gut ding braucht
weile inhalt gibt es auch
lohnunterschied drinnen
heiden hhk befindet war 30 10 mm okay
auf jeden fall ist die panne jetzt heißt
jetzt macht mal den cut sowie die kirche
ist so also jahrelang eine geisterbahn
gearbeitet
[Musik]
ob die stadt oder ich kann mir so ein
crack pipe machen
du wurdest backen lassen gab es doch
gesagt du blödmann zog ich zeige euch
jetzt mal die braucht deine haare die
hätte ein ich mach uns welches einen
einzigen kann man nichts machen kann
schon jetzt ein machen die nur eine
douglasie machen das lass deine finger
weg
[Musik]
alles gesehen hast einfach gesehen
die traut einfach nur zack ich hatte es
nur die lockout mein gott erzählt schatz
wir haben bedingt benutzt werde ich mir
seine zutaten kann nichts falsch machen
das haben die mühe gemacht sollten jetzt
kann ich jetzt der ruf von alleine rund
80 schüler seien von dir sehen es gebe
entwicklung einmal möglichkeit sein
ganz wichtig ist den franken noch einmal
zu wenden
es ist saumäßig wichtig weil ich weiß
ich habe jahrelang 72 78 montreal in
einer kräftige arbeiten jetzt rutscht
einfach runter siehst du das aha jetzt
macht man am nächsten kommt machen
alleine aber so wie es die frau gemacht
habe die hatten es anders gemacht denn
oben angefangen zu der schon blöd ich
habe es mir aber gesagt länger drin
schnell macht die löcher zu
ich muss mich nicht heiß sein und er
muss richtig schön durch gebacken sein
dann lässt er sich leicht entfernen sie
das wahnsinn jetzt macht vitali von der
obere natürlich runter er muss 1000 euro
behalten heißt macht macht da ja auch
kinder
und hätte man jetzt darfst du mal machen
nein doch jetzt macht um nein du bist
selber finde ich glaube ich bin der ein
geber- und du bist ja bände
was bist du total kleber bin ich gibt
auch gelte es gibt ja auch gleich
ländern gebe so jetzt machst du mal ein
gekommen
doch jetzt macht auch geschichtlich
gewinnst du lachen aber eingestellt
große kunden ich hab keinen große du
auch sehr kleine osmani gut gemacht hat
jetzt einmal hier eine ganz süße
auflaufform ist man folgendes jetzt
nehmen wir hier ein pinsel und tun die
auflaufform ein bisschen einfetten mit
zerlassener butter mit zerlassener
butter genau die war es vor allem in den
zutaten nicht mit drin
muss ich jetzt ehrlich sagen aber es ist
kein problem jeder ein bisschen butter
geheim
jetzt haben wissen eingecremt jetzt mal
folgendes jetzt nehmen wir hier so ein
crêpe sondern richtig cool wie toll und
jetzt tun wir den füllen mit
vanillepudding verteilt
hast du vorher durchgeführt aber okay
das war auch so und jetzt ist es schön
einrollen mit erdbeeren sind kommt die
braune und wieder hoch das sei ein
bisschen vanille zucker noch zimt zucker
tschuldigung der zauber oder ja ach so
dann machen wir das nicht machen
es war ein fehler jetzt wolle man das
einfach mal so zusammen waren sind es
riecht schon richtig lecker dann stellt
sich trage man muss länglich oder machen
muss breit länglich oder fried ja kommt
es nur wenn also ich hab doch gesagt du
tun wollten sagte er hört mich auch
nicht wieso muss ich mich ihm
zusammenarbeiten
du kannst du nur längs ratschläge waren
breit ich habe hier sinn macht so lange
so wäre es doch besser aus dafür nehme
ich jetzt ein japanisches shaqiri messer
center macht japan ist ja jetzt das ist
ein davon erzählen was wird da macht mir
sagt genau das ist ein japanisches
markiere das messer machen wir das
gerade weiter günther machte darüber
keine sorgen so schön jetzt
ja man könnte auch noch gefroren und
flüchte ryanair fürchten brauchen
natürlich dinge reinlegen irgendwie sind
wir machen
fanny michaela das ist dann das
japanische meer saß löschte oder
apfelstücke kann auch rein machen ist
mir gerade noch einen gefallen so das
ist aber cool und ist was ganz ich finde
es auch so richtig schön rustikal aus
ich glaube da bist du auf jedem wo bist
du da auf jeden taiwan bisher akin war
richtig schön zusammengerollt und jetzt
tun dass hier durchschneiden
jetzt wollen wir noch zehn züge
obendrauf
und zwar hier und dann das wasser ja
stimmt genau
gleichzeitig waren zwar in einem heute
lernt man sagen auf jeden fall muss ich
euch eins zu geben das ding ist wirklich
eigentlich einer städtischen gut gesund
ist natürlich nicht widersetzen butter
mit dem zucker hat für das öfter nein
sagst du okay jetzt tun muss einfach mal
rein und gucken was passiert und zwar
tue ich das hier rein in den backofen
hier mittlere schiene hat es jemand
gesehen und zu ist alles von alleine
und was jetzt wie viel grad schatz also
ist gleichsam 170 grad ober unterhitze
noch nicht wurden 90 grad ober
unterhitze und dann ungefähr für zehn
minuten musst du selber was man so von
der zwischenzeit macht die dinge weiter
da hat man sofort
er habe ja wir haben ungefähr so sieht's
aus der zucker karamellisiert wollte ich
aber auch nicht das ist ein trick
gewesen von mir und zwar machen mir
folgendes wenn meine frau kommt gleich
wie man ein bisschen auf dicke hose
machen aber das ist wahnsinnig
professionell aus wenn jetzt der flammen
mehr von nutzen so
aha aha die kindersicherung drin und
zwar mache jetzt war es hier
okay okay
ja genau ein bisschen zucker drüber ich
habe es doch gleich gesagt dass mir so
machen muss hat sagte kusch
wir bekommen jetzt überhaupt machen das
zuhause bitte nicht nach und jetzt will
ich mal meine frau gebieten das zu
probieren liebe diesen röstaromen
das riecht verbrannt war
aber ich finde es echt gut und ich hatte
stets auf eigentlich wer ist auch
vorschläge gewesen wäre glücklich
gewesen wäre brauchte ich hab da nichts
dran sei fruchtig nicht okay aber sei
ehrlich weil die zuschauer mainz nach
kanada sowie im kochstudio so machen
dass er nicht selbst probiert da machte
hier alle zusammen
[Musik]
ehrlich jetzt war es echt gut
juni hat auch grün jetzt mal ehrlich
toni selbst gemacht der politiker ist
der ehrliche noch nie gerne ist der
wahnsinn oder jetzt probiert das erste
mal halt bis jetzt neu in den leuten
halbjahren in dieser bühne gibt hat er
noch nie selbst gemachten pohling
vergessen er spielt zuerst so einfach
ich möchte ich nicht von der gabel essen
von der er gekostet hat und auch lassen
doch die schwämme probleme mit der mama
wenn ja wird zum star machen definitiv
interessiert nicht
man kann ja auch das ganze mit schoko
pudding machen der muss einfach nur in
den vanille bedingungen entweder
bisschen herren schokolade einrühren
oder kakao oder man kann ich helfen nur
dunkel machen das wäre nochmal eine
zutat mehr da kommst du durcheinander
habe ich recht also einfach einen
vanillepudding herstellen halbieren und
in die andere hälfte chocolat rein und
dann sagt man das am 2 es ist halt immer
nicht mehr zu sagen dass für uns
beim guinness ganz wichtig nicht mehr
zutaten als auch finger hat genauso ich
komme das durcheinander das sagt gerade
richtig
das niag einem finger kriegt diesmal
dessen stimme sagt okay alles da vielen
dank macht's gut macht's besser und
haben sie den spaß gemacht und alles
gute
gehörten vor ostern nächsten paar tagen
ist weihnachten und neujahr genau wenn
sich ein rein fasching genau
und dann kommt da genau kann man dann
kommt auch noch alles gehabt macht's gut
ist
[Musik]
ganz drohnen halterung wo der wo der
mann tag an meiner mama anrufen
aufkochen und kennst du den trick wie
menschen mehr anbrennt wenn die milch
aufkochen mehr anbrennen nein das habe
ich mir gedacht okay erzählt hast du
schon mal gutes gemacht fasste audi was
ob dass man einen iq-test nicht gemacht
sparte das geld hätten wir anziehen als
wenn sie mich anziehe
nein es gibt mich wenn ich es ehrlich da
gibt wirklich wir schauen viele klubs
auch nicht mehr genügen müssen müssen
echt aufpassen wieder finden sie nicht
begleiten weil hier sind kinder die
schauen zu weil die haben heute nicht
erwartet
jetzt kommen wir zwei haben dann schauen
wir mit solchen riesen augen zu sehen
sie dich bereit ist hier beleidigen
ich hab' ich werde das hier bereitet
internet naja so am besten wenn du bist
ok sachen überlegen sie mal ganz wichtig
wenn ich mich an den grünen hin lehne
ein widget da kann ich dummheit zu
erhören wo man in basel in basel wo man
auf dem hotelzimmer zusammengeschlagen
ich habe noch nie mit jetzt noch immer
glauben dir auch so
doch kann man das ausschneiden nein da
wohl als ich nachts wach bin und du auf
mir gelungen ist was ich wohl zu
kuscheln
[Gelächter]
wenn man karten waren
ich war mit ihm gesprochen
ich habe noch nirgends ist sagen die
leute kennen mich okay du das bringen
wenn meine frau muss das ja alles schon
gesagt wo du nicht da war es gar nicht
haben doch jahres beleidigt nein doch
der hat alles gesagt noch was war das
mindert so kleiner mensch was haben ein
kleiner publica typisches merkmal was
war das ja das war mal das war vorher
das war vorher
aber er fängt immer an schweren gang
hatte und beleidigt nicht immer ach ja
da machte sachen über meine ethnische
herkunft über meine größe über meine
intelligenz dann sagt ich werde nichts
nutzt nein ich habe nur gefragt ob du
schon mal an iq test gemacht hat gesagt
nein in afrika spar dir das geld weil
jetzt machst du denn fertig ja ich finde
es toll hammer ich meine ich finde es
wirklich dass wir das als männer so hin
gemacht haben immerhin verlief nicht wie
du bist der könig war der krebs bist ja
ich bin minister klar ist dagegen ist
der krebs hast du das gesehen und das
nächste machst du jetzt habe ich möchte
auch mal das glück sagen das ist ja in
den himmel jetzt durch schaue ich die
ganze geschichte hier
du bist ja man schleimbeutel gibt doch
ziemlich voll beleidigt
na ja schon sachen gesagt nein das macht
da könne nicht ausländische mülltonne
genannt hatte hat er gesagt aber wenn du
mir so drauf ansprechen